what exactly is the content likely to be
well from the democrats what you're
likely to hear
is how terrified they personally were
and also
all of their other arguments which is
that the riots were white supremacy
trump is a white supremacist
you're likely to hear about how close we
were to losing our democracy in the
words of representative jackie speier
from california democrat
she says you know we have to hear during
this trial how close we were to losing
our democracy now let's be frank about
this we were not close to losing our
democracy
we weren't i mean we just weren't as a
factual matter
a bunch of yahoos idiot criminal yahoos
evil yahoos running into the capitol
building and putting their feet on nancy
pelosi's desk it's ugly and it's
terrible
and it's bad and it's horrible for the
country that was not us being close to
losing our democracy you know losing a
democracy looks like it sort of looks
like
what happens in countries all over the
world when the military just marches
into presidential palaces and starts
arresting officials right that's what it
looks like
at no point was this a coup a coup is
not a bunch
of idiots dressed in buffalo horns
running into a government building and
sitting in somebody's chair that is not
a coup
by the way it's not even a coup if
somebody goes and tries to murder
members of congress
that is an act of evil a criminal act of
eagle okay by the way we've seen it
before
okay it is not even it is not even a
coup when
god forbid a president is assassinated
we've had that in american history
before that's not a coup either
a coup specifically speaking is when one
regime is exchanged
for a more legitimate regime through the
mechanisms of
institutional power generally right
that's when you have the military
that intervenes on the behest of one
political party for example
and then house a sitting democratic
democratically elected person for
example that is the nature of a coup
this was not a coup
we were not close to losing our
democracy how close were we to losing
our democracy within hours of these
morons
jumping into the capitol building to
make trouble and videotape themselves
for their for their instagram
congress was back in session ratifying
the election
and making joe biden the president of
the united states so yeah we were not
close to a coup
but again the the lie has what's amazing
is that you don't actually have to do
this
i mean seriously democrats don't have to
do this i said this the day of this
could have been a unifying moment
that lies are bad and people believing
lies is really bad
and people then acting on those lies to
do violence and terrible damage
is really really bad we can all be on
the same side of all those questions but
instead it's
well you know donald trump tried to
launch a coup and he almost he was
barely thwarted no he wasn't
he was not barely 40. you know how i
know he wasn't he wasn't barely thwarted
because on january 20th he didn't attend
the inauguration and joe biden became
president of the united states so that's
how i know he wasn't barely thwarted
it's just the exaggeration is
unnecessary
and it really does demonstrate that what
this really is about for a lot of folks
as always is the pr right we have a
congress that doesn't actually do
anything for a living we have a congress
that tweets things and goes on cable
news
they have the same job that i do except
that i'm not paid by taxpayer money
nor am i your elected representative
right we have a congress that does not
pass bills we have a congress that does
not negotiate we have a congress that
does
nothing except every once in a while
they vote on some giant omnibus spending
package they toss all power over to the
executive branch a bunch of unelected
bureaucrats govern your life
and then congress goes on twitter and
talks jack about other people that's
that's pretty much what congress does
for a living these days
here's jackie speier doing just that
again i there's no wonder why people
hate
the american legislature there's a
reason the legislature does not
legislate
our elected officials do not represent
us all they do all day long
is just yell on cable news for power
it's pretty crazy
i intend like so many of my colleagues
to
put into um words that every american
can hear for decades to come how close
we came to losing our democracy
this is a man that intended to overtake
this government and it's astonishing to
me
that so few of my colleagues on the
republican side even after witnessing
that even after being part of that
insurrection are unwilling to do their
jobs
and protect the constitution and protect
the democracy
okay again the democracy was not under
threat okay there were people who
were threatening to do bad things at no
point was the institutional democracy of
the united states under threat
to pretend otherwise is to ignore the
realities on the ground
the military would not have participated
in anything like that republican members
of congress voted to ratify the election
vice president pence was the vice
president under donald trump plus we
forget
he was the person leading the
ratification mitch mcconnell was the
head of the senate
like all of this overwrought hysteria is
in fact
overwrought hysteria i'm not saying it's
hysteria to have been worried or
concerned or freaked out at what
happened at the capitol it is
overwrought hysteria to say that america
was on the brink of turning into a
dictatorship on january 6. that's just
silly
it's silly on its face it's silly in
just a second we're getting more silly
because again this is really not
about anything to do with trump it's
really just about the pr
that you can that you can use in order
to foment your own rise to power in the
future via social media
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content